[Music]
you were here you said you it's very
important to to promote someone else's
project which is very unusual
celebrities usually don't do that yeah
I'm good friends with these guys Tim and
Eric you know and they you know they're
involved in this show that this this guy
they know and they asked me to help out
he he just had a DVD come out of all of
his shows and apparently some kind of
doctor who gives advice but his name is
dr. Steve Brule some people might be
aware of it anyway cuz they asked me
like please please if you can help out
our friend Steve he needs all the help
you this guy helps people yeah he helps
me get advice about relationships and
your body and health and stuff like that
his big catchphrases for your health
okay that sounds I mean this sounds very
useful you brought a clip yeah these are
a promo for this DVD that he's released
recently yeah okay well let's take a
look at this guy Steve Brule
promotional bit could help you yeah talk
it out
watch my show Charles dr. Steven Brule
it was on TV
dingus why don't you watch it guess what
you don't have to watch anymore enough
you can just have it
watching your VCR
[Music]
we see very nice man John that's clearly
you not he was wearing glasses Connie
okay all right well you've convinced me
I guess I'm an ass I guess I'm an idiot
yeah well there is a similarity but yeah
yeah all right what about a doctor no no
no would you ever pretend to be let's
talk about wreckit-ralph this is a
project that you are actually in yeah
john c reilly s are in recognize isn't
it your voice yeah I'm curious animation
you don't have a lot of experience was
this is it pretty simple doing the voice
or did you were you kind I was a bit of
a novice
yeah I can't went in there thinking like
I've got to do everything it's like
radio I've got you know so like I was
providing sound effects like
manipulating my face like there's one
part where a bug jumps on my face I was
like finally like John we're gonna add
that stuff we can do a lot of filtering
of your voice like don't you don't have
to punch yourself in the face if your
character gets punched in the face and
then by then it was too late I was
bleeding but no I it was really really
really fun and we did a lot of
improvisation and Sarah Silverman's in
it and Jack McBrayer and Jane Lynch so
there's some really talented people in
it and it's got a lot of heart believe
it or not let's say you know it's nice
you're also gonna get when you said when
you said that the audience just started
filing out part
[Music]
we have a we have a clip here from
wreck-it Ralph anything when you ask but
well I think this is the thing in the
beginning he before he goes off on this
adventure to find himself he he goes to
a bad anon meeting which is like a
12-step program for bad guys and video
games and yeah so you'll see some
familiar faces at the Badnaam meeting I
think let's check out this clip from
wreck-it Ralph I don't want to be the
bad guy anymore mess with the program
Ralph you're not doing turbo turbo no
I'm not going turbo come on guys there's
a turbo don't want a friend or a metal
or a piece of pie every once in a while
is a turbo a lot more out of life Ralph
Ralph we get it but we can't change who
we are and the sooner you accept that
the better off your game and your life
will be Hey on gaming at the time Ralph
now let's close out with the bad guy
after me
I am bad and that's good I will never be
good I mean that's not bad there's no
one I'd rather be
[Applause]